okay this is a
peppa pig saga level 3 or
434 walkthrough tutorial one of the
members of our
facebook group is having trouble with
this level
and there's basically a trick to it so
i'm going to go ahead and
try to play through it and explain it um
in the very beginning you just have a
bunch of little matches so you don't
have to worry about those what we're
trying to do first is to open up this
ice because the purple peppers we need
are in these crates so i'll talk about
that more later but right now i'm just
going to try to blow
a couple yellows and couple blues
sorry i'm still recovering from a cold
and um
i got a little bit of a cough left over
so yeah like i said these ones you don't
have to worry about at all they just
they're gonna happen whether you try to
or not so
yellow and blue first
and there's really not that big of a um
advantage of shooting these either so
you don't have to worry about going on
your way to do that either
and since these spots are so small up
here you don't really have to you know
worry about uh panic starting by
accident or anything
all right so now we're down to our five
pepper
and the trick is is that since this
match is already set up in these
the trick is just do not open the middle
one until last
so if we have ones in the top and the
bottom you know
and let's say if we open the top three
then the three purples are going to
match and that's going to stop
us from making the big one so if we
leave this one intact until very last
then
that will give us an automatic five
pepper match if we can do it
so we're just going to work on opening
those up as best we can
it's really not that bad
except for you know obviously we don't
have any control on where these things
fall
you can get stuck at times um
i don't love this because it's gonna
it well it's not going to open it
because we got three that are that stage
so i'm just going to go ahead and make
this but you have to be careful later if
you do that because
like here for instance um
all right so now we're going to lose
this purple pepper anyway so
i don't know it wasn't growing all right
so
i'm going to open this one and this one
and then that one last
so we'll see if we can do that
no we didn't on that side but we have
another one here
so you can see that's the problem if you
open that one first
then everything gets screwed up
um purples do drop as you can see
frankly though i've always been able to
get it by doing this when i've done it
so it's
i guess if you have a lot of moves left
and you mess up both sides then you can
try to set up the five
but it's not the easiest way that's for
sure
all right so make sure you don't make
this much obviously
this is gross right here um
that's not good for us but let's see
what happens
yeah the purple's kind of getting away
when you get one of the sides wiped off
but
i wouldn't say it's over yet still got
12 news so let's see
we could make this match except for it's
going to pull that one out
we really need to get something going on
here so
there we go all right so all right
that's what you want to set up
you want to save that one till last and
then watch when i make this yellow match
it's going to make our five
oh no it's not all right so let's see
what can we do instead if i make the
yellow match this purple one's gonna get
trapped and we're gonna lose it so
we're gonna have to work around this
somehow
this isn't going to be easy because
these two green ones are stuck in there
um yeah
okay so that'll work so i'm going to
shoot this and you'll see
there's our five that's the level
all right so if you have any questions
leave a comment but you know that's the
main thing leave that middle one there
and um your match will happen
automatically for you
like this video if you found it helpful
that really helps me out a lot and um
good luck